كما قال المتحدث باسم الجيش الاسرائيلي
دانييل هكاري ان القوات انهت تفكيك ما
سماه الاطار العسكري لحماس في شمال غزه
وقدم ه جاري شرحا مطولا لعمليات الجيش حتى
الان في غزه واشار الى ما وصفها
بالانجازات لكنه سلط الضوء على الوقت
الطويل الذي استغرقه انجازها وكشف ان
الامر استغرق ثلاثه اشهر لهزيمه حماس الى
حد كبير في شمال القطاع ومنع كتائب الحركه
من هجمات واسعه النطاق حسب ما
قال لقد انتهينا من تفكيك الاطار العسكري
لحماس في شمال غزه وسنواصل تعميق الانجاز
وتعزيز الدفاعات على الحدود لقد ضربنا
وسنواصل الضرب ومستمرون في تعميق الانجاز
في هذه المجالات لكن الامر يحتاج الى وقت
سنفعل ذلك بطريقه مختلفه وبطريقه شا
بناء على الوس التي تعلمناها من القتال
حتى الان سيستغرق الامر وقتا والقتال
سيستمر طوال عام
2024 ونحن نعمل وفق خطه لتحقيق اهداف
الحرب تفكيك حماس في الوسط والجنوب
ومواصله كل الجهود والضغط الاستخبارات
والميدان لاعاده الرهائن
من رام الله معنا اللواء واصف عريقات
الخبير في الشؤون العسكريه اللواء واصف
الى ما قاله المتحدث باسم الجيش
الاسرائيلي حققنا انجازات استطعنا تفكيك
ما وصفه بالاطار العسكري في شمال غزه وفي
المقابل نشاهد هذه الفيديوهات للمقاومه في
التفاح في الدرج في اكثر من محور عمليات
ما زالت مستمره وبالتالي كيف نفهم ما قاله
المتحدث بانه انجاز عسكري وتفكيك لهذا
الاطار الاطار العسكري
لحماس يعني بالتاكيد
ما قاله الناطق العسكري لو رجع الى اربع
ايام سابقه حينما طلب رئيس هيئه الاركان
هالفي لمجلس الوزراء من اجل ان يقدم تقرير
ميداني عن الانجازات التي تم تحقيقها
اعتذر وقال بالحرف الواحد و وهو تصريحه
موجود حتى الان انه حينما يتلاءم ذلك مع
الظروف الميدانيه يعني يحضر الجلسه حينما
يكون هناك انجازات ميدانيه وتتلائم الظروف
المناسبه
بمعنى ان رئيس هيئه الاركان لم يكن بحوزته
اي انجاز عسكري ليقدمه امام الكابينت او
امام مجلس الحرب وامام الوزراء هذا من
جانب من جانب اخر انا
اعتقد الناطق الناطق العسكري نفسه يعرف ان
هناك اشتباكات تدور في كل مكان سواء كان
في الشمال او في الشمال الشرقي او في
الشمال الغربي او في غزه او في خان يونس
وما دام هناك
اشتباكات وهو يقول تم تفكيك يعني في ال
علم العسكري تم تفكيك يعني انهاء اي
مقاومه وانهاء اي اي قدره قتال ولكن حينما
يكون هناك اشتباكات وحينما يكون هناك قصف
من سلاح الجو الاسرائيلي وقصف من المدفعيه
البريه وقف وقصف من المدفعيه البحريه هذا
يعني ان الجنود الاسرائيليين غير قادرين
على السيطره على المكان فبالتالي هو يتحدث
وكانه يعني لا يخاطب ناس لديهم عقول
ولديهم معرفه وانا اعتقد
يعني الداخل الاسرائيلي الكتاب والمحللين
الكل الاسرائيلي يتحدث عن عدم تحقيق
انجازات حتى حتى الان فما هي هذه
الانجازات التي تم تحقيقها لو هناك
انجازات حقيقيه لشاهدنا بالافلام التي
تبثها هيئه الاعلام الاسرائيليه سواء كانت
عسكريه او مدنيه ولكن لا يوجد لديهم اي
انجاز حقيقي حتى يبثه على وسائل الاعلام
حتى ولو افترضنا ان ما قاله المتحدث باسم
الجيش الاسرائيلي يحمل هامش من المصداقيه
عندما نتكلم عن فتره ثلاثه اشهر حتى الان
وما زالت العمليات مستمره وما زال النيه
من قبل الجانب الاسرائيلي تحقيقها هذه
المره جنوبا ماذا عن هذا المعطى معطى
الوقت
والزمن يعني حينما يقول رئيس الوزراء
سنقاتل حتى تحقيق الاهداف ويقول رئيس هيئه
الاركان سنقاتل خلال طول طول العام 2000
24 وهناك 120,000 جندي اسرائيلي لهم ثلاث
اشهر لم يحققوا اي انجاز حتى الان سوى بعض
يعني الانفاق وبعض الخنادق وليس كل
الانفاق وليس كل الخنادق هذا في بعض
المناطق وليس في كل المناطق صحيح ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي تمدد وصل بدباباته وبيات ولكن
هناك فرق ما بين التمدد وما بين التطويق
والتطهير هناك مرحلتين على الجيش
الاسرائيلي ان يقوم بتنفيذها وهي مرحله
مرحله التطويق تطويق الاماكن وخاصه خ خان
يونس وتطهيرها تطهيرها بمعنى ان الجندي
الاسرائيلي سيتحرر من الدبابه
وسيتحسن وجها لوجه مع المقاتل الفلسطيني
في الشوارع الضيقه في الحارات ويستطيع
حينها تحقيق الاهداف اما ان يكتشفوا نفق
دفاعي في طرف خان يونس في شمالها في شرقها
هذا شيء طبيعي نعتقد هو ليس انجازا
الانجاز الحقيقي السيطره والثبات على
الارض وهذا حتى الان لم يحدث من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي